despite a career year in 2019 cowboys
quarterback dak prescott couldn't reach
a long-term deal with the franchise
before the july 15 deadline for doing so
on wednesday both jerry and steven jones
were asked about those negotiations
we think he's outstanding we think he's
our quarterback of the future
we just couldn't get together at this
particular time
i think it's easily worth noting
that uh a lot of people this year in the
franchise mode uh didn't get together
one of the biggest reason is the
backdrop
of of the covet
one of the biggest reason is the
economic issue
i've just spent weeks and weeks a part
of this rash voice on the phone talking
with nfl and the players association
weeks and weeks working through
the economic consequences
and candidly nobody knows what's going
to be there next year next year or the
next year and frankly we all know that
what we were talking about in dak's case
was the next year and the next year and
the next year and the next year
so all of that came to bear and this was
just a
less than stable time
to be talking about
serious serious generationally if you
will to use daxter
dollars
in an unknown period of time looking
forward everybody was pretty much aware
at the end of the day that uh you know
the term of the deal was a a big part of
this and uh but at the end of the day it
doesn't change the way
we think about dak dak and i had a great
visit uh right there at the deadline uh
he's so fired up about this team about
this season and about our future and uh
we ultimately know uh that we're gonna
have to figure out how to get this done
i i'm more convinced than ever that we
will get it done but because of uh the
moving parts that we were dealing with
with the virus
of course you know you throw in some
other deals that were done which were
certainly not down the middle in terms
of being normal or
a normal contract
it just made for some challenges
that's both jerry jones and stephen
jones and i have a ton of respect for
what the jones family has done for the
cowboys in the national football league
i talked to stephen at least once a year
on pftpm i enjoy visiting with him again
a ton of respect and this is all the
setup for me to say i don't buy any of
what was just played chris here's the
bottom line
they resisted and have consistently
resisted offering dak prescott the kind
of contract he wants and they have
believed at the end of the day he would
buckle
and
agree to the deal that they want him to
take and he has continued to say no
no and no and it keeps getting more and
more and more expensive and the idea
that it's difficult or impossible to
structure a long-term deal in this
climate well it's going to be a hell of
a lot harder next year to give dak
prescott 37.68 million under the
franchise tag if the salary cap drops to
175 and by rule that's what he's going
to get unless they go back in and change
the cba over the rules for paying a
franchise tag player in year two when he
gets a 20 raise over what he got in year
one it's 37.68
it would have been easier to do a
long-term deal with the four-year
extension that he has consistently asked
for not five years it would have been a
lot easier to do that than to put
yourself in a spot where you're paying
him 31-4 this year 37-68 next year and
facing a future in 2022
where you don't know what's going to
happen 45 million 54 million or out the
door that's what's looming in about 18
months for dak prescott and the cowboys
if they don't work this out next year
and they should have worked it out long
before right now well yeah they should
have there's no doubt about that i mean
they should have got them in a bargain
deal a year ago they could have saved
themselves a whole lot of money i mean i
think we and i discussed that many times
yeah they're in a dangerous spot right
now there's no doubt whether it's the
franchise tag next year whether it's the
fact that hey dak prescott's really
freaking good and i do believe the
cowboys love him i do and they think
he's the franchise quarterback and they
want to pay him i don't deny that either
i mean i i think they really do i also
agree with what you said mike and i've
heard this from people in the know that
yeah i think they they're a little
caught off guard by you know how strong
dak prescott has stood here as far as in
negotiations i think they thought that
that he at some point would just kind of
settle for that somewhat of a
team-friendly deal because he's such a
team guy and such a leader that way and
he's very humble and it comes off right
away when you're where's that where's
where's the side eye control room
where's the dak prescott side on right
when chris said that to him face to face
well that's we've known yeah we've known
we have since since early 2019 we've
known he wasn't going to play that game
and what makes why didn't the cowboys
figure it out well what makes it scarier
too you know i know jerry i mean he says
he watches all the media and he's you
know he's got he needs to watch me i
mean i would have you watch my podcast
you would have known dak wasn't gonna
settle for this deal a while ago but
they're also in danger here yeah there's
a side eye mike you love it no
[Laughter]
i don't know if that's whether i said
he'll take a team-friendly deal or if i
asked him your big spoon i'm little
spoon i'm not so sure
no no that was that was you seem like a
guy who isn't real selfish and will take
a team-friendly deal and that's when he
did that yeah yeah right so
but what's scary too mike and i think
you'll agree
is statistically this year in a new
offense cd lamb to go with amari cooper
and michael gallup and ezekiel i mean
you know they could be
like the greatest show on turf this year
you know i mean they could be that type
of team high flying ball everywhere dak
prescott throws for 4 900 yards and 40
touchdowns and 10 interceptions and whoa
is the price gonna go up so yeah
obviously there was that argument over
the fourth and fifth year of the deal
the cowboys wanted five dak prescott
wanted four
you know we haven't really heard what
kind of numbers dak prescott has asked
for
that to me
you know we've heard that the cowboys
have offered in that 35 million a year
rage i have heard nothing from the other
side to say no we're kind of asking for
this and then a course with stephen
jones at the end there says
you know there's another contract the
mahomes contract he was i think
acknowledging that right mike to go damn
that threw us a curveball and everything
and that's why we are where we are
but dak wouldn't have taken the mahomes
no i know i don't know if the cowboys
would have offered them a homeschool
yes i know
no the the cash flow over the first
three years is embarrassingly low the
signing bonus is embarrassingly low the
full guarantee at signing is
embarrassingly low other than that it's
a good contract dak prescott
the thing here's what's great about dak
he's not affected by the business aspect
he's not going to carry it around in a
negative way if anything is just going
to motivate him back when he signed his
franchise tender my understanding was
that he just looked at and said look i
did a contract year last year at two
million i'll do a contract year this
year at 31.4 million and i'm going to go
out and i'm going to show up and i'm
going to be at practice i'm going to
bust my ass to be the best quarterback i
can be and then next year takes care of
next year when they either give him the
long-term deal that he wants
or they pay him 37.68 million for one
year and the question will be just like
it was this year what will the cowboys
give him to get him to trade in what
he's got next year
3768 plus the doomsday scenario for the
cowboys in 2022 it's gonna take a lot a
lot more next year than this year to get
him to trade in his rights under the cb
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports